thank you good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen and apologies for keeping you
waiting
first of all I would like to say how
happy I am to be with you for my first
EPS go count councillors Commissioner
for health and food safety and I would
like to start by thanking the finished
presidency in particular Minister Carew
for excellent cooperation during this
presidency and running such a smooth
meeting today thank you so much Minister
our first discussion today focused on
the economy of well-being because we all
know that a sustainable Europe means a
Europe that works for each and every
citizen and where citizens are placed in
the center of where decisions are taken
a sustainable Europe is a Europe which
has a health in all policies and health
and economy if we think about it are the
two sides of the same coin this is
precisely what I aim to achieve as
commissioner
to ensure that health is reflected in
all policy areas and that people
citizens and patients are put at the
center this morning during our
discussions are highlighted three
priority areas to the ministers which in
my view are particularly important the
first one is the area that has to do
with cancer
arian the priority for myself very
important a huge burden on the economy
huge burden on citizens but most of all
it causes a great deal of suffering as
we all know I have informed the
ministers that I am glad to announce
that on February 4th which is World
Cancer day I will start an inclusive
discussion based on the Europe beaten
cancer plan I believe that there is only
one way to be truly effective to fight
cancer and that's by making it a truly
European endeavor with this plan we will
support member states to reduce the
suffering of cancer in Europe and it
will be an opportunity to show the
citizens what Europe can do for them and
I think that this can really bring us to
the heart of the European citizens
secondly I informed ministers that I
will work to create a European health
data space to maximize the potential of
digital technologies in health and this
can be a true game changer for our
cancer plan because fighting cancer
without opening borders for services and
health data will not work and thirdly
I'm very glad that part of the
discussion today was about promoting
good mental health
it really is imperative that this
finally receives the attention that it
deserves people too often with mental
health problems are living in silence or
are forgotten and mental health needs to
be understood as a cornerstone as part
of the economy of well-being and I am
there to try together with all the
ministers to try and ensure this we had
a fruitful discussion on the euro on the
pharmaceutical policy I fully share the
concerns and often justified worries of
the EU citizens concerning affordable
method medicines and from day one in
office I try I've been working on this
file and I was very happy that this put
on the agenda of this council my mission
is to try and bring all stakeholders
together on board so and to improve
accessibility and affordability of
medicines in this respect I really do
need to emphasize my thanks to Minister
cure for her efforts in the council to
advance then the negotiations over the
Commission's health technology
assessment proposal this proposal is
vital if we are going to move forward
and it does affect the policy area of
shortages of medicines it's important
that we move on this file together with
the new creation presidency I also read
it very clear to ministers that I am
fully committed to the deadline of May
2020 for the implementation of the new
medical device regulation the new
medical device regulation for most of
you probably know that this is essential
for patient safety a lot of work needs
to be done
the
we're all working together not wasting
any time to make sure that we implement
this regulation in time it's going to be
a rough road bumpy road at times but I
will do my best to deliver on what my
mandate has entrusted me with which is a
health and food safety of European
citizens and thank you again Minister
Curie for the excellent work
congratulations undertaken by this
finished presidency and I look forward
to working with the creation presidency
thank you thank you very much